[Musik]
nicole kidman tates cristiano ronaldo
und kim kardashian auch sie bekamen
kinder mit hilfe einer leihmutter
jedes sechste paar bleibt weltweit
kinderlos ungewollt und tendenz steigend
die oft letzte hoffnung einer
leihmutterschaft oder eizellenspende das
ist in der schweiz verboten
ein äußerst heikles ein sensibles ein
schwieriges thema wir wagen ein gespräch
herzlich willkommen zur sternstunde
religion herzlich willkommen im haus der
religionen in einem hotel in der ukraine
warten babys auf ihre auftrags älter
diese konnten während des lockouts nicht
ins land reisen um sie abzuholen
die bilder sind um die welt gegangen
sascha ist ein wunschkind eine
leihmutter hat es zur welt gebracht
das französische fahrer hatte zuvor alle
medizinischen möglichkeiten ausgeschöpft
in frankreich ist leihmutterschaft
verboten ebenso in der schweiz oder in
deutschland
deshalb weichen paare ins ausland aus
etwa in die usa oder in die ukraine
die ukrainerin natalia hat bereits zwei
eigene kinder
das kind in ihrem bauch trägt sie für
ein paar aus dass anderswo lebt seit ich
in das programm eingetreten bin seit ich
erfahren habe dass es losgeht habe ich
meinen job gekündigt um in ruhe
schwanger zu sein
die leihmutter erhält einen lohn für
ihren einsatz
oft sind agenturen oder kliniken im
spiel welche die leihmütter suchen
beraten und vertragliches regeln einer
leihmutter wird in der regel eine
befruchtete eizelle oder ein embryo
eingesetzt
samen und eizellen können von den
auftrags eltern oder von spende eltern
stammen
so ist es möglich dass bis zu drei
frauen und zwei männer beteiligt sind
die leihmutter die spenderin der spender
und die auftrags eltern
das heißt es sind bis zu drei frauen im
spiel eine genetische die eizellen
spenderin eine austragende leihmutter
sowie eine aufziehende wunsch mutter
trotz verbot sollen in der schweiz
geschätzte 1000 kinder aus einer
leihmutterschaft leben
die dunkelziffer ist hoch
leihmutterschaft ist tabuisiert aber
welche rechte haben leihmutter etwa in
der ukraine oder in den usa können sie
vor ausbeutung geschützt werden und was
ist mit den kindern wie werden sie mit
ihrer herkunft klar kommen
ja ich begrüße heute bei mir
annika könig medizin ethnologin ruth
baumann hölzle medizinethikerin und
theologen und antje schrupp
politikwissenschaftlerin und theologin
herzlich willkommen schön dass sie hier
sind
später in der sendung werden wie noch
nie zu sehen er hat zusammen mit seinem
mann drei kinder aus leihmutterschaft in
den usa herzlich willkommen
ja ich beginne gleich hier mit einer
auslegeordnung frau könig sie sind wie
gesagt medizin ethnologin sie schreiben
ihre habilitation momentan zum thema sie
befassen sich also schon ziemlich lange
damit sie haben mir gesagt es gab ein
gesinnungswandel was verstehen sie heute
besser als zu beginn der arbeit
naja wenn man anfängt empirische
forschung hat man ja bestimmte
vorstellungen erst mal also wir
versuchen natürlich möglichst neutral
daran zu gehen aber wir haben natürlich
bestimmte ideen im vorfeld und schauen
dann ob die sich in der realität
bestätigen oder nicht und ich muss sagen
ich bin extrem kritisch an das thema
leihmutterschaft herangegangen und
forscher jetzt seit mittlerweile 2013 zu
dem thema
das heißt es sind einige jahre ins land
gegangen und habe relativ schnell als
ich angefangen habe mit den leuten
wirklich zu sprechen die beteiligt sind
also wunsch eltern aber auch leihmütter
und andere beteiligte gemerkt dass das
ganze doch sehr viel komplexer ist und
sehr viele verschiedene sichtweisen und
erfahrungen dort beinhaltet sind die ich
vorher einfach nicht erwartet habe frau
baumann hölzle
wie gesagt medizinethikerin aber auch
evangelische theologin
sie sind grundsätzlich gegen die
kommerzielle leihmutterschaft haben sie
das auch mal anders gesehen
es stellt sich immer die grundfrage
natürlich in der medizinethik überhaupt
wie können wir in der gesellschaft aus
menschen person sein und wann gibt es
und werden wir zur sache auch zur
handelsware
und das ist so gleicht die kernfrage fsv
team zurückkommen werden naja und 2000
ist so die kern frage inwiefern werden
wir menschen instrumentalisiert hat
rauchwaren versachlicht und insofern gab
es für sie keinen gesinnungswandel in
bezug auf die antwort auf diese frage
nein ich denke spitzt sich sogar immer
mehr zu weil ich denke menschliches
leben
das geboren wird wird zunehmend auch
instrumentalisiert und die frage
wie weit gehen wir in der ausbeutung
auch des menschen respektive wir haben
die welt die erde ausgebeutet und jetzt
machen wir uns daran auch und menschen
selbst auszubeuten das ist noch die
frage wie weit soll die
kommerzialisierung gehen wie weit werden
jetzt zur sache
jetzt nehmen sie schon viele von
argumente vorweg wir kommen darauf
zurück vielen dank frau
politikwissenschaftlerin ebenso
evangelische theologin
im grundsatz sind sie ja eigentlich für
leihmutterschaft zumindest unter
gewissen wie soll ich sagen umständen
oder mit gewissen schranken auch in dem
buch das sie aber geschrieben haben
kürzlich sie haben sich nämlich auch
länger damit beschäftigt schwanger
werden können
da hatte ich das gefühl sie wollen sich
nicht so recht festlegen
weshalb ist das so naja war der
leihmutterschaft dass sie bei vielen
ethischen fragen die wir momentan
diskutieren dann einfaches pro und
contra ist keine sinnvolle antwort ich
bin der meinung dass es keine natürliche
art und weise gibt wie erwachsene und
kinder sicher gesellschaften wie
familien sich gründen sondern dass das
wir als gesellschaft entscheiden müssen
und ich finde es spricht nicht
prinzipiell etwas dagegen wenn
erwachsene miteinander vereinbarung
darüber treffen dass nicht die versuchen
die ein kind geboren hat eltern dieses
kindes ist sondern andere es kommt eben
darauf an wie die umstände von
leihmutterschaft oder wie man darf
ernennen will
sind es gibt da keine keine
prinzipiellen ethischen bedenken dagegen
meiner meinung nach sondern die frage
ist gelingt es uns als gesellschaft das
eben menschenfreundlich im sinn des
guten lebens und im sinne des wohls des
kindes der erwachsenen der beteiligten
und auch natürlich der schwangeren zu
regeln und ich glaube dass man das gut
regeln kann und dass man nicht bei der
bisherigen oder traditionellen rein
biologischen definition von elternschaft
bleiben muss gut wir wollen dass während
des gespräches aufschlüsseln
jetzt schauen wir mal was die
landeskirchen denn überhaupt zum thema
sagen
die schweizerische bischofskonferenz
etwa hat sich 2014 ganz klar gegen
leihmutterschaft ausgesprochen der
katholische frauenbund hingegen sie
haben
auch in der position nächtlichen
positionspapiers und dann was ihn da in
der argumentation dafür und dagegen aus
wegen wollten sie sich eben nicht klar
positionieren und der schweizerische
evangelische kirchenbund hat bisher
keiner stellungnahme zur
leihmutterschaft veröffentlicht in der
recherche das sehen wir jetzt auch
anhand dieser drei punkte habe ich
festgestellt dass sich auch die
christlichen kreisen nicht gerne
festlegen wollen oder noch keine
festgelegten meinungen haben sie nicken
was deshalb denken sie ist das so wenn
man kann natürlich ganz verschiedene
perspektiven einnehmen dahingehend wie
wir quasi mit christlichem hintergrund
auch mit neuen themen umgehen wollen
die es früher so nicht gegeben hat und
wir sind eine gesellschaft die
pluralistisch ist und da stellt sich
immer die frage wer darf wo wie man
quasi auch stellvertretend für andere
menschen dann entscheiden und die
kirchen selber denke ich haben sich auch
in die vergangenheit natürlich sehr oft
auch stellung bezogen in situationen wo
man im nachhinein sagen muss das war
seine menschenrechtlichen perspektive
nicht angemessen
und ich glaube daran gibt es auch so
eine gewisse zurückhaltung und für mich
persönlich der menschenrechtliche
aspekte oder auch diese aufgrund
entscheidungskriterium eigentlich das
wichtig wie das führt mich jetzt zu
einer nächsten frage sie beide als
theologinnen hat denn die religion zu
diesem thema überhaupt etwas zu sagen
und wenn ja weshalb frau schob na ja ich
würde sagen die religion und die
christliche religion speziell müsste
sich erst mal selbstkritisch mit ihrer
geschichte auseinandersetzen und das
haben sie auch gerade gesagt in bezug
auf frauen recht auf ihr für alle hat ja
die christliche religion immer sehr
restriktive biologistische
naturalistische positionen vertreten
und man müsste jetzt erst mal verstehen
woher kommt das war da was falsch daran
inso in bezug auf frauenrechte war da
was falsch dann wird
sagen auch in bezug auf ehe für alle und
deswegen ist für mich jetzt kein wunder
dass die christliche religion natürlich
die erste autorität ist so was ethisch
zu beurteilen ja und da müsste man eben
mal größer die frage der sexualität aus
christlicher sicht revue passieren
lassen um dann wieder in eine position
zu kommen wo man dann auch andere
ethisch beurteilen und vielleicht auch
verurteilen kann
ihre meinung hat die religion etwas dazu
zu sagen als die die grundlinie der
religion von der auslegung her
wenn sie sich daran orientiert dass
menschen respektiert werden sollen
kreuzt sich natürlich in der grundlinie
der menschenrechte und der menschenwürde
das heißt nicht dass die kirche
dahingehend nicht in der vergangenheit
natürlich große fehler gemacht hat auch
große missstände es gegeben hat und
leider immer noch gibt
deshalb ist die argumentationslinie für
mich nach wie vor eine starke
menschenrechtlich orientierte und was
natürlich in den kirchlichen aus senden
in der christlichen ethik vor allem
jetzt im neuen testament fehlt ist
eigentlich so die ganz starke soziale
ethische argumentationslinie es ist eine
sehr individuelle tische
argumentationsweise welche sich und der
nächstenliebe orientiert und wir haben
eigentlich wenig die perspektive der
sozialethik und für mich selber jetzt in
dieser fragestellung der
leihmutterschaft oder wie man sie danach
benennen will da werden ja noch sicher
darüber reden
ich denke gerade sozial ethische
argumentationsweise tragend und wichtig
werden wir jetzt etwas konkret da gehen
wir auf die perspektive der leyen
frau könig sie haben mit vielen leine
dann auch gesprochen für ihre forschung
viele treibt natürlich um was sind
eigentlich die beweggründe dass eine
frau leihmutterschaft macht das ist
natürlich eine ziemlich schwierige frage
und das ist natürlich auch die erste
frage die mir immer gestellt wird ich
denke was ich erst mal wichtig findet zu
betonen ist dass wir gar nicht
leihmutterschaft als einen fest
stehenden begriff sehen können sondern
es gibt bei mutterschaft in ganz vielen
verschiedenen ausprägungen
das heißt ich präferiere auch
tatsächlich er diesen begriff im plural
zu verwenden als leihmutterschaften weil
es einfach ganz viele verschiedene arten
und weisen gibt das zu leben und das ist
natürlich auch was was die leihmütter
selbst betrifft also es ist ein ganz
großer unterschied ob sie jetzt zum
beispiel mit einer amerikanischen
leihmutter sprechen die in kalifornien
lebt oder mit einer ukrainischen
leihmutter die vom land in kiew kommt
oder mit einer indischen leihmutter die
in hyderabad lebt zum beispiel also das
sind schon mal große unterschiede
es gibt natürlich diverse verschiedene
motivationen dafür und eine motivation
die ja auch vielfach kritisierte ist
natürlich das geld das ist ein punkt der
von vielen als sehr anstößig
wahrgenommen wird weil diese diese
gleichzeitigkeit von intimität und
fortpflanzung und gleichzeitig der der
der monetarisierung ist sowas da geht es
um ganz großes unbehagen entsteht bei
vielen von uns das ist eine motivation
die aber auch sich im laufe einer
leihmutterschaft durchaus ändern kann
und es gibt auch frauen und das ist ganz
interessant weil das ist dieser
religiöse aspekt das ist durch dass ich
durchaus auch leihmutter getroffen habe
die argumentiert haben oder als grund
gegeben haben dass für sie wirklich
nächstenliebe dieses anderen menschen
helfen tatsächlich im vordergrund stand
und dass das gerade in den usa teilweise
auch wirklich sehr religiöse frauen sind
die sagen dass sie dieses gut familie
einfach so hoch schätzen dass sie
anderen familien das auch ermöglichen
möchten da geben wir genau es gibt auch
frauen mit denen ich gesprochen habe die
gesagt haben dass sie jetzt in ihrem
direkten umfeld infertilität mitbekommen
haben die freundin die schwester oder
irgendwie sowas und die sagen dass es
ein schicksal was sie niemandem wünschen
wo sie eben da sozusagen ihr talent oder
sozusagen ihre fähigkeit ein kind
auszutragen
damit dieses leid mildern wollen und so
weiter also es gibt diverse motivation
man kann das jetzt gar nicht auf eine
motivation so unterbrechen
ich sehe das auch das hängt ganz stark
auch damit zusammen wo die
leihmutterschaft durchgeführt wird
ich möchte auf den ersten punkt gleich
eingehen natürlich treibt es ganz viele
leute um das geld wir haben im vorfeld
zuschauer via facebook gefragt was sie
denn von leihmutterschaft halten
und da haben wir ich nehme zwei heraus
zwei beispiele
michelle beschreibt uns wieder einmal
eine sache die nur mit und wegen geld
funktioniert und l toni schreibt auch
eine form von seinen körper verkaufen
also verkaufen die frauen ihren körper
frau könig das ist ein bisschen
ansichtssache denke ich es hängt auch es
hängt so ein bisschen darauf davon ab
von welcher perspektive man sich das
anschaut es gibt durchaus auch den
ansatz zu sagen es ist eine
serviceleistung oder es ist eine art von
arbeit für die ich bezahlt werde genau
und eine sehr geschätzte kollegin von
mir hat zum beispiel in israel zu diesem
thema geforscht und wo es eben als
ausbeuterisch angesehen wird wenn frauen
nicht dafür bezahlt werden weil da
dieser hintergedanke ist dass frauen das
so oft von frauen erwartet wird care
arbeit also für sorgearbeit unbezahlt zu
machen dass sozusagen in israel er
dieser ansatz vorher struck gesagt wird
kein geld zu bezahlen ist die
eigentliche ausbeutung während jetzt zum
beispiel in der schweiz oder in
deutschland tendenziell die kritik er
ist dass man sagt frau machen das nur
wegen geld aus finanzieller not heraus
das heißt dieses ein kind gegen geld
austragen ist sozusagen der
ausbeuterischen aspekt jetzt möchte ich
natürlich das wort an frau baumann
wetzlar übergeben sie haben da eine
klare meinung dazu
was mein ist für mich ist es eine form
der schwangerschaft konstitution also
weil es fließt ja geld für das ich
meinen körper verkaufen und wir
überschreiten zunehmend ein nicht die
haut um quasi unseren körper auch zu
kommerzialisieren
das ist bei der schwangerschaft so das
ist auch zum beispiel bei der nämlich
der frauen wenig die zunehmend auch
verkauft wird und hier auch wild banken
entstehen zu kommerziellen zwecken als
die für mich ist die kernfrage wie weit
gehen wir in der kommerzialisierung von
unserem körper als ich mir die frage
wieweit verkaufen wir unsere organe
wobei natürlich bei einer leihmutter
situation ich kein organ verkaufen
sondern es sich um ein kind handelt dass
hier mit im spiel ist und für mich kommt
die leihmutterschaft schon sehr nahe
dann auch in den kinderhandel wenn wir
schauen wie teuer wie viel geld
natürlich hier sich das ist ein gängiges
vorurteil oder vorurteil ebenfalls wird
es oft gebracht wir kommen darauf auch
zurück auch die frage wird wenn ein kind
gekauft oder wird die dienstleistung
bezahlt ich möchte das klären
ich möchte zuerst auf diesen punkt dann
gehen es gibt auch ein unterschied von
leihmutterschaften es schon angedeutet
je nachdem was gemacht wird gibt es eben
auch verschiedene modelle also gängig
schreibt euch spricht man von
kommerzieller leihmutterschaft oder eben
altruistischer leihmutterschaft frau
könig können sie uns das mal ganz kurz
erläutern was ist der hauptunterschied
war auch das ist nicht so einfach
also erstmal spricht man jetzt generell
von kommerzieller leihmutterschaft wenn
diese leihmutterschaft gegen die zahlung
von geld durchgeführt wird
altruistische leihmutterschaft darunter
versteht man eine leihmutterschaft bei
der die leihmutter kein geld bekommt das
ist aber gerade weil der altruistische
leihmutterschaft gar nicht so einfach
denn zum beispiel in großbritannien ist
es so dass nur die altruistische
leihmutterschaft erlaubt ist aber eine
aufwandsentschädigung gezahlt
erhöht und das heißt dann zwar
altruistische leihmutterschaft de facto
ist die summe die eine frau bekommt
relativ ähnlich wie sie ist wenn sie zum
beispiel in anderen ländern eine
kommerzielle leihmutterschaft kann man
die grenzen nicht so gut diese grenzen
sind eben nicht so eindeutig gezogen
genau und insofern lässt sich diese
differenzierung zwar machen aber wenn
man genau hinschaut es ist eben auch
wieder doch vielschichtiger als es auf
den ersten blick scheint und macht diese
unterscheidung für sie ist die
wichtigste ja ich finde es auch ein
bisschen schwierig weil ich glaube dass
das größte problem für die leihmutter
ist nicht dass sie geld bekommen
das problem was sie haben ist eigentlich
ihre rechtliche situation oder so da
können wir dann ja vielleicht noch mal
darauf zu sprechen kommen ich wäre auch
dagegen dass als kinderhandel zu
bezeichnen weil kinder können kein
eigentum sein man kann kinder allein
schon deshalb nicht verkaufen weil man
sie nicht besitzen darf ist was und dann
übertragen wird das hat der status der
elternschaft und elternschaft verstehe
ich nicht so dass man ein kind dann
besitzt ja wir haben aber diese
tradition auch in der in unserer
klassischen ehe form dass man sagt sie
schenkt ihrem mann ein kind so wir haben
dieses negativ dass frauen kinder
gebären und sie dann hergeben so zu
sagen und das und in dem kontext sehen
wir dann eben auch die leihmutterschaft
und sagen okay da schenkt sie es nicht
sondern sie bekommt geld also ist es
kommerzialisiert aber ich glaube das
trifft nicht das phänomen also ein grund
warum derzeit ja viele leihmütter
bezahlt werden ist ja dass zum beispiel
in deutschland und der schweiz ist nicht
erlaubt ist zum beispiel unter
freundinnen das zu verschenken also sind
die paare die das wollen darauf
angewiesen ins ausland zu gehen
aber sie kennen natürlich keine
amerikanerin die sie so gut mit ihnen
befreundet ist dass ich ihnen jetzt ein
kind gebärt also müssen sie es sozusagen
diese dienstleistung kaufen das ist aber
eine folge der art und weise wie wir es
generell organisiert haben wenn es bei
uns kulturell ganz normal wäre dass
nicht alle kinder bei denen frauen
bleiben die sie geborgen haben sondern
auch von anderen erwachsenen groß
gezogen
dann bräuchten wir vielleicht die
kommerzielle leihmutterschaft gar nicht
weil wir andere formen hätten kinder
zuzuordnen und sage ich mal das ist
natürlich ein
ein haupt argumentation strand von ihnen
den sie auch in diesem buch ganz stark
machen darauf kommen wir zurück schauen
wir uns doch das mal ganz konkret an
also beispiel ukraine wir haben uns zu
beginn auch in ein spieler gesehen in
der ukraine etwa kann man sich für 64
1900 euro an vip package kaufen
inklusive pränataldiagnostik
hotelaufenthalt chauffeur und umhänge
bauch für frauen die zu hause eben die
eigenen schutz vor schwangerschaft
vortäuschen wollen ein
hundertprozentiger erfolg ist garantiert
frau baumann al islam
natürlich denke dass es sehr idealisiert
ist jetzt wie also für mich wirklich
beschreiben weil der kontext mit der die
reproduktionsmedizin überhaupt und ließ
natürlich schon stark industrialisiert
das sind immense auch finanzielle
interessen im spiel bei der
reproduktionsmedizin überhaupt ich meine
es geht ja dabei auch nicht nur nicht
nur quasi darum dass man andere menschen
zu einem kind kommen die kein kind
bekommen können sondern es sind
agenturen im spiel und die
reproduktionsmedizin so wie wir sie
heute haben es wirklich an in eine
industrie geworden und diese
kommerziellen interessen im hintergrund
sind natürlich ein starker anreiz dass
das eine das andere wenn wir empirisch
schauen dann ist es schon so dass
eigentlich normalerweise schlecht
gestellte frauen quasi diese leistung
verkaufen weil sie sonst in der
gesellschaft frauen sowie möglichkeiten
haben unter umständen um überhaupt einen
guten beruf auszuüben
und da stellt sich dann schon die frage
wieweit verstärken wir natürlich mit
solchen möglichkeiten für mich sind
diese dieser einstieg von diesem auto
ist ischen da kann man eigentlich nicht
viel dagegen haben so das problem ist
das sehen die immer stark bügel
argumente für mich jetzt welche
natürlich dann eigentlich letztendlich
diese große kommerzialisierung
ausblenden die da wirklich schon im
hintergrund läuft aber verlief im
geschäft gibt es für sie keinen
unterschied zwischen dieser kommt also
macht das für einen unterschied zwischen
kommerzieller
und als touristischer leihmutterschaft
ziehen sie da eine grenze oder ist das
für sie quasi gleichermaßen
ausbeuterisch also wenn eine frau
wirklich freiwillig in einer idealen
welt ein kind für eine andere frau
austragen würde dann kann man sagen sie
macht ihr das individual ethisch zu
einem geschenk nur wir leben nicht in
einer idealen welt und das problem ist
dass eben die ganze reproduktion
zunehmend nur schon der begriff
reproduktionen oder ist zu einem solchen
markt geworden und und diesen markt
zementiert nun einfach wirklich
ungleichheiten ungerechtigkeiten wer
kann sich das schon leisten und das
andere ist danach in diesen ländern ich
mein wenn wir nach indien geschafft
haben diese frauen wurden in häusern
gehalten wo man quasi etwas sagen konnte
sie waren gleichsam fast wie frauen
fahren ich möchte da nur kurz
unterbrechen weil indien ist ja
heutzutage auch nicht mal das beste
beispiel das hat sie hat sich viel
verändert
es ist auch bekannt wie problematisch
die situation dort ist ja genau das ist
da bin ich natürlich völlig ihrer
meinung das muss das skandalös und das
muss geändert werden
die frage ist nur wie ändern wir das
also ich denke mir wir leben einfach in
einer sehr kapitalistischen durch
kommerzialisierten welt und ich bin
immer skeptisch wenn ausgerechnet das
was frauen beitragen können aus der
kommerzialisierung langsamer werden
sollen also ich finde kommerzialisierung
ist in bezug auf umwelt verstörung auch
ganz problematisch also da geht es auch
um unsere lebensgrundlagen und wir
müssen sozusagen aufhören ich mag dieses
bald um nicht die männer machen gute
kommerzialisierung und wenn es um frauen
geht und ihre arbeit dann muss auch
alles geschenkt werden sonst schmeckt
der absolut mehr wenn ich denke also die
die das ist die frage der
kommerzialisierung und das andere ist
natürlich die frage der sozialen
ausbeutung unbedingt müssen wir
wirtschaftspolitische rahmenbedingungen
und soziale verhältnisse schaffen wo
keine frau gezwungen ist das zu machen
um ihre miete zu bezahlen
alle frauen müssen in der lage sein zu
sagen nein das will ich nicht
ich verdiene mein geld anderswo aber
wenn frauen heute nicht in der lage sind
das zu sagen helfen wir ihnen ja nicht
indem wir die leihmutterschaft verbieten
sondern wir würden ihnen ja nur helfen
wenn wir ihnen andere
einkommensmöglichkeiten versammelt
da brauchen wir ein paar fakten also in
der ukraine zum beispiel für das
publikum oder was heißt wenn ihr mir die
ganze zeit über kommerzialisierung
sprechen was fließt dafür geld wir haben
zuvor das vip package gehört aber man
kann leihmutterschaft in der ukraine ab
40.000 circa machen 16.000 so diese
zahlen habe ich mitbekommen fließend
circa an die leihmutter sie können mich
dann korrigieren
in den usa ist es einiges teurer erstens
stimmt diese zahlen so und zweitens
fühlen sich die frauen denn auch gekauft
ich meine jetzt sprechen wir die ganze
zeit über die person sie haben mitten
personen gesprochen also erstens nein
die zahlen stimmen nicht so also erstmal
ist es so dass wir auch in der ukraine
und das möchte ich auch noch mal betonen
wirklich ganz ganz viele verschiedene
arten von agenturen haben
dieses beispiel was sie genannt haben
genau das ist eine agentur die er sehr
viel werbung macht und die so dass auch
bei google immer oben steht und so das
ist die agentur die immer so als
beispiel genommen wird die vielleicht
aber auch nicht unbedingt repräsentativ
für alle arten von agenturen ist also es
gibt ja sehr unterschiedliche modelle
und meines wissens also ich habe ja
leihmütter interviewt in der ukraine ist
es eher so dass sie ein bisschen weniger
bekommen also er so um die zwölf bis
14.000 das ist für uns vielleicht nicht
so ein großer unterschied ist aber
natürlich dort ein sehr großer
unterschied
in den usa ist es zwar mehr aber es ist
jetzt gar nicht so wahnsinnig viel mehr
im vergleich also in den usa ist es so
dass die leihmutterschaft unter anderem
auch deshalb so viel teurer ist weil
dort diese ganzen medizinischen
prozeduren so viel teurer sind
das heißt in der ukraine können sie eine
iv 11 für wesentlich weniger geld
durchführen lassen als in den usa
verbieten fertige setzte und
entschuldigung
genau das ist der eine punkt nur das ist
sozusagen
da muss man aber auch wieder schauen pro
agentur wie unterschiedlich wird es
irgendwie geahnt
dann ist es so zu ihrer zweiten frage
fühlen frauen sich ausgebeutet das ist
eine frage die ich die frauen den frauen
immer stelle und nicht irgendwie direkt
am anfang und wie sieht es denn aus und
das ist natürlich was das ethnografische
methode erfordert ja auch erstmal
vertrauensaufbau und das ist auch in der
intimen situation ist wo jetzt nicht
irgendwelche leute dabei sind die die
kontrollieren und so weiter und
interessanterweise haben auch diese
ukrainischen frauen alle mit denen ich
gesprochen habe gesagt nein wir fühlen
uns nicht ausgebeutet wo wir uns
ausgebeutet fühlen ist wenn wir zwei
oder drei jobs gleichzeitig machen
müssen und trotzdem nach hause kommen
und unsere kinder nicht ernähren können
das ist natürlich jetzt das macht ich
verstehe ihre kritik natürlich
vollkommen dass das natürlich nicht die
problematik der kommerzialisierung
verringert trotz alledem ist es
schwierig ist einfach so sie haben
vorhin gesagt dass es empirisch bewiesen
dass es eben frauen mit niedrigerem
einkommen und wunsch eltern mit höherem
einkommen machen
dem würde ich auch nur so halb zustimmen
weil es schon so ist dass diese
differenzen nicht immer unbedingt so
groß sind
also das ist durchaus auch frauen gibt
die aus besseren besseren finanziellen
verhältnissen kommen und zum beispiel
gerade in den usa viele agenturen auch
nur frauen als leihmütter annehmen die
finanziell nicht von davon abhängig sind
dh auch da müssen wir schauen dass es da
auch sehr unterschiedliche setups gibt
und das ist doch vielleicht ein wenig zu
vereinfachend ist zu sagen dass es eben
einfach arme frauen sind die das aus not
heraus machen
ich persönlich habe diese frauen
wirklich überraschenderweise weil ich
eben auch sehr kritisch daran gegangen
sind als extrem starke und auch sehr gut
informierte frauen empfunden und eben
eigentlich in vielerlei hinsicht
überhaupt nicht dieses klischee erfüllen
dass wir uns eben hier oft vorstellen
ich sehe das hier argumentieren jetzt
ganz stark empirisch das ist ja auch
genau
ich möchte aber trotzdem noch kurz ein
argument der schweizerischen
bischofskonferenz aufnehmen
die nämlich sagen leihmutterschaft
verletze die würde der frau durch die
ermöglichung des verkaufs seiten
europas wir sind da ein bisschen bei
ihrer argumentation dann sagen sie aber
noch und das finde ich besonders
interessant und des verkaufs eines
wichtigen bausteins ihrer weiblichen
identität frau schrieb ja genau das ist
eben das problem warum die kirchen da
eigentlich war so gut mit treten können
weil sie den frauen sozusagen das
gebären können als ihre identität
verkauft haben und das ist doch
skandalös
das ist doch nicht die identität der
frauen das ist die identität der frau
wäre das jedenfalls das nicht aber es
ist machst das was du zu sagen stimmt
ist eben dass wir als menschheit vor der
situation stehen dass wir vielleicht
alle kinder haben wollen oder eltern
sein möchten aber nur die hälfte von uns
kann schwanger werden das heißt wir
müssen das irgendwie organisieren dass
diese eine hälfte die schwanger werden
kann und die kinder die dabei zur welt
kommen verteilt werden auf alle
erwachsenen und das ist momentan im
umbruch weil die klassische christliche
favorisierte methode ein mann eine frau
zu einem ewigen paar zusammenbinden und
der mann hat dann alle rechte über die
frau übrigens funktioniert nicht mehr
wir haben gleichgeschlechtliche paare
wir haben allein stehende frauen wir
haben eben viele frauen auch die nicht
schwanger werden können
aus den verschiedensten auch sozialen
und gesellschaftlichen gründen und jetzt
ziert sich das neu und viele der
probleme die wir haben
die kommen ja nicht auf dem
kommerziellen und auch nicht aus dem
ethischen sondern die kommen aus der aus
dem rechtlichen aus dem gesetz das ist
nämlich verbietet auf eine andere weise
kinder und erwachsene zusammen zu
bringen als durch die klassische ehe und
das ist das problem was dann auch die
agenturen lösen diese ganzen rechtlichen
hürden irgendwie zu umschiffen die in
den herkunftsländern das macht es dann
teilweise auch so teuer weil es der
normale oder der einfachste weg ich kann
nicht schwanger werden ich fragt meine
freundin ob sie es für mich macht der
geht ja aus rechtlichen gründen nicht
weil wir diese diese tradition nur die
frau die das kind geboren hat ist die
mutter wenn wir die haben und die können
leute alleine gar nicht auflösen weil
das illegal ist und dann fängt dieser
ganze ganz ungünstige komplizierter
prozess an der unter anderem auch
leihmutterschaft enthält genau sie
nehmen sie jetzt vorweg einfach noch mal
dass wir das
haben die die rechtliche lage
leihmutterschaft ist in der schweiz
nicht zulässig und zwar nach dem artikel
119 der bundesverfassung
es macht sich aber nicht strafbar wer
eine solche im ausland durchführt dann
allerdings ist es so dass die schweiz
das rechtliche kindes verhältnis zu
einem ausland mittels leihmutterschaft
geborenen kind nicht in jedem falle
anerkennt und deshalb möchte ich jetzt
auch gerne übergehend zu der perspektive
der wunsch eltern die da eben ganz stark
mit hineinspielt leben von den wunsch
eltern sprechen oder den auftrags eltern
dann sind das ganz oft paare
heterosexuelle paare das muss man ja
einfach gesagt haben es gibt oft andere
andere argumente die eingeführt werden
es sind aber tatsächlich die mehrheit
heterosexuelle paare
frau könig sie sie nicken also ich finde
das schwierig zu sagen weil ich
natürlich keine zahlen habe als jetzt
irgendwelche zeit ist eine große reform
die tendenz denke ich stimmt und die
versuchen halt jahre lang kinder zu
bekommen unerfolgreich wo dann die
leihmutterschaft quasi in die bresche
springt frage in die runde warum wollen
denn eigentlich menschen so gerne kinder
haben truppe ja das ist ja auch eine
gesellschaftliche sache weil man uns
frauen dass er als unser wesen verkauft
hat und wenn man kein kind hat ist man
ja nicht eine normale frau
das haben wir ja so gelernt und ich
glaube dass auf diese weise auch
gesellschaftlich dieser wunsch mit
hervorgebracht wird
ich persönlich kann es ja sagen ich habe
keine kinder und nie den kinderwunsch
gab ich verstehe es auch nicht
aber menschen sind ja in gewisser weise
herdentiere was alle machen machen wir
auch und wenn alle glückliche kleinen
familien sind dann entsteht das defizit
bei den personen die das nicht
hinkriegen aber sich das immer erträumt
habe schon als kleines mädchen
vielleicht das heißt ich sehe da
durchaus auch eine gesellschaftliche
möglichkeit diese diese negativen
aspekte der der leihmutterschaft
abzumildern indem wir das narrativ
ändern und sagen es gibt glückliche
menschen die haben keine kinder geboren
auch frauen ja und dann gibt es
vielleicht diese nachfrage nicht aber
ich denke mir mal das
dass das wird es nicht sind wir das
beurteilen können den wunsch der
einzelnen so wenn der wunsch da ist
finde ich muss ja auch ernst genommen
werden aufgegriffen werden und man kann
nicht sagen
jetzt pech gehabt wobei ich allerdings
sagen würde man kann nicht sagen es gibt
ein recht auf kinder das wird manchmal
auch diskutiert dass menschen ist hat
ein recht auf auf fortpflanzung die
fordern sozusagen die legalisierung von
leihmutterschaft inklusive finanzierung
als menschenrecht da bin ich nicht der
meinung dass das so ist weil es ist eben
teil der menschlichen natur dass wir
nicht alle kinder gebären können
da müssen wir mit zurecht kommen wenn
ich ein kind haben will und kann ich
selber schwanger werden brauche ich die
freiwillige mitarbeit einer person die
schwanger werden kann
ich habe da kein recht braucht also das
würde ich festlegen wenn ich da ein
gesetz schreiben dürfte aber wenn ich
alle finde ist es okay
sie sehen nachdenklich aus ja weil ich
denke der kinderwunsch ist etwas sehr
komplexes natürlich auch es sehr viele
gesamtgesellschaftliche aspekte das
denke ich auch
ich habe mir von ihnen einfach überlegt
ja wie stark sind wir geprägt jetzt
ausgebaut frauen quasi kinder haben zu
müssen wegen der gesellschaft und ich
glaube diese erklärung allein reicht mir
nicht aus ich denke es ist wirklich wie
manche frauen ist es ein wirklich ein
sehr existenzielles bedürfnis das dann
umgestellt ist die frage ist wie gehen
wir als gesellschaft generell mit
umgestellten bedürfnissen um und ist das
vergleichbar mit anderen bedürfnissen
ich finde es steht mir überhaupt nicht
so hier etwas zu sagen wie fern dass wir
werden ein kinderwunsch nur
gesamtgesellschaftlich seinen ursprung
hat oder nicht ich glaube das wissen wir
letztendlich auch nicht ganz ich frage
mich einfach in was für einer
gesellschaft wollen wir leben was für
möglichkeiten sollen frauen sollen wir
frauen haben und
noch einmal was mich wirklich immens
beschäftigt ist schon wie weit wollen
wir eigentlich die kommerzialisierung
noch treiben dass sie plötzlich den
körper verkaufen die organe verkaufen
ich meine es war eine derartige
errungenschaft dass wir die sklaverei
abgeschafft haben
es war eine errungenschaft dass der
mensch als person respektiert wird und
zwar nicht zur sache gemacht und dieses
immense kulturgut ist derart gefährdet
gerade in heutiger zeit und wenn wir
hier beginnen unter der haut wieder zu
verkaufen ich meine prostitution die
gibt es und die frage setzt wollen wir
das noch erweitern
natürlich es gibt verschiedene
produktionsformen ach da gibt es
beziehungen und so weiter aber inwiefern
wollen wir hier das noch weiter fördern
dass wir jetzt nachdem wir alles schon
kommerzialisieren
auch noch den menschen kommerziell war
das ist für mich die kernfrage ich würde
wir können danach gleich anhänglich
möchte kurz einer person das wort geben
die selber kinder aus leihmutterschaft
hat damit auch an der person die das
kennt damit sprechen kann bei uns ist
chisora wie pinto man spricht in bezug
auf dieses thema immer wieder auch von
gleichgeschlechtlichen paaren die
therapie pinto sie haben drei kinder aus
leihmutterschaft zusammen mit ihrem mann
diese kinder sie haben hier extra fotos
mitgenommen zwillinge haben sie kürzlich
aus der usa
können sie mir erklären weshalb haben
sie kinder aus leihmutterschaft weil wir
zwei männer sind und keine kind kriegen
natürlich jetzt bei uns ist von dem her
sind uns die möglichkeiten ein bisschen
eingeschränkt worden und adoption ist
auch nicht möglich moment von dem einen
war die einzige möglichkeit für uns eine
leihmutterschaft ja und dann macht man
sich schlau und schaut herum wo es
möglich ist und wo nicht punkt
indien wo davor sich in angedeuteter
erfüllung kam für uns nicht in frage
eben wegen dem ethischen problemen und
da blieben nach kanada und amerika übrig
und schlussendlich wurde amerika war
mehr zufall
hier sieht man das mädchen von der von
der einen leihmutter sie haben danach
eben kürzlich noch zwillinge von einer
anderen leihmutter weshalb sind es zwei
verschiedene leihmutter bei der geburt
ältesten tochter von bayer an gab es
probleme mit der geburt und deshalb
wurde sie beim zweiten mal eigentlich
ausgeschlossen ist die klinik an tanz
geprüft und der relativ seriös gemacht
und dann haben sie gesagt dass sie nicht
mehr weiter hinaus tragen dass sie darf
schwanger werden natürlich mit ihrem
partner
aber die klinik mache das nicht dass wir
keine klinik geben die da eine die eine
eizelle einsetzen einsetzen würde
es ist eine persönliche frage sie
offenbaren sich ja hier auch ich habe
das gefühl sie sind sehr betroffen auch
von von dem was hier besprochen wird wie
geht es ihnen wenn sie so was hören dass
es eben alles durch kommerzialisiert
wird sie haben drei kinder und sind sehr
glücklich mit diesen kindern ja
natürlich
das geld spielt eine eine für mich eine
untergeordnete rolle ich meine
schlussendlich ist eine dienstleistung
die sie erbracht hat und meine das ist
kein verkauf von einem kind das seine
mutter sagt immer man hat mir nichts
weggenommen ich gebe etwas zurück was
mir eigentlich aus geleitet wurde es
gibt es zurück und von dem her ist es
auch richtig und feiert das die für
diese zeit für diesen ausfall denn sie
hatte auch geld erhält und das ist nicht
wahnsinns lohn denn sie bekommt von dem
herrn ist okay also ich finde es ganz
wichtig dass das so gelaufen ist und
kann sie etwas mehr dazu sagen was sie
für ein verhält
bis zu diesem leihmüttern haben damit
man das einordnen kann ein sehr gutes
verein müssen so wir haben vor wollen
metall ist mir auch mit lucia inside
inniges verhältnis
wir hören uns mehr rot wenn ich so alle
zwei wochen mit lucia jetzt ein bisschen
mehr weil sie natürlich immer fotos
krieg von den kleinen zu gelangen
aber im schnitt erinnert sich einmal im
monat kann man sich danach wie ich dort
eine videobotschaft darin facetime kommt
darauf an wie die zeit ist und wie man
gern beschäftigt ist aber kontakt ist
sehr innig und das wollen wir auch und
das war uns wichtig ganz herzlichen dank
für ihre offenheit war wie winter
[Applaus]
ja frau könig jetzt bei
gleichgeschlechtlichen paaren die können
nicht verstecken dass die kinder aus
einer leihmutterschaft haben bei
heterosexuellen paaren hingegen wird es
oft verschwiegen das ist ein tabu auf
jeden fall also leihmutterschaft ist auf
jeden fall ich denke im gesamten
deutschsprachigen raum stigmatisiert
tabuisiert wir im übrigen auch andere re
produktionstechnologien also es hat sich
zwar geändert dass ein bisschen mehr
darüber gesprochen wurde aber wenn man
einmal anfängt über diese themen zu
sprechen wundert man sich doch wie viele
leute dann doch
also diese technologien in anspruch
nehmen und bei einer leihmutterschaft
ist es schon so dass eben auch durchaus
trauen sich dann falsche bräuche
umschnallen also ich habe jetzt gerade
eine eine frau im sinn mit der ich
kürzlich gesprochen habe mich auch schon
eine weile begleitet die ihr kind jetzt
gerade demnächst bekommen wird in der
ukraine und die einfach auch angst hat
vor den reaktionen in ihrem umfeld von
irgendwie den reaktionen in der
nachbarschaft wird und reaktion bei
ihrer arbeit und wo der engere kreis
durchaus weiß es in der leihmutterschaft
in auftrag gegeben haben aber wo diese
ängste vor stigmatisierung und vor auch
vor den reaktionen auf die kinder
einfach so groß sind dass man doch
lieber diese sachen halt versucht zu
verstecken
und das ist natürlich ein riesengroßes
problem denn ich habe auch mit einem par
oder ein paar interview die gesagt haben
dass das der grund ist weshalb sie es
ihrem kind nicht sagen können weil sie
einfach angst haben dass dieses kind
dann später irgendwie dafür aufgezogen
wird oder schlecht behandelt wird und
das sozusagen der art und weise wie die
gesellschaft dann eben mit diesen themen
umgeht dazu führt dass dann ebenso
sachen passieren die die eltern gar
nicht wollen wo die eltern nämlich sie
haben ja auch angesprochen
eigentlich auch alternative
familienformen wie auch als positives
erleben
im alltag und eben dann die art und
weise wie diese wie diese technologien
stecken aktiviert werden dazu führen
dass das eigentlich nicht so gut läuft
wie es laufen laufen könnte auf die sich
des kindes kommen wir dann nachher auch
noch zurück ich möchte ein die zeit
läuft uns leider davon das ist ein
hochemotionales thema ich möchte ein
zuschauer kommentar noch einblenden von
anna wie schurter die nämlich aufnimmt
was zuvor hier auch gesprochen
besprochen würde ich habe ihnen
versprochen wir kommen darauf zurück sie
schreibt man hat kein recht auf ein kind
schön wenn es klappt aber man kann auch
ohne gut leben man forscht heute zu
stark in die natur kinder sind keine
ware ja ja das ist genau der punkt
das problem an den reproduktions
technologien und wie sie genutzt werden
sind meiner meinung nach nicht die
kommerzialisierung kommerziell ist auch
ein problem aber das hauptsächliche
problem was ich sehe ist dass sie nur
verwendet werden um vermeintlich
natürliche familien zu imitieren das und
das liegt an den gesetzen die zum
beispiel sagen nur heterosexuelle paare
bis zu einem gewissen alter dürfen diese
technologien in anspruch nehmen und ich
finde wenn schon natur dann ganz natur
dann muss man die generell verbieten für
alle
aber was jetzt passiert ist es wird die
einen dürfen weil sie dann nämlich dass
faken können sie können sie sehen von
außen so aus als wären sie an natürliche
familie
was sie aber nicht sind weil sie diese
technologien in anspruch nehmen müssen
und dann fängt diese heimlichtuerei an
dann fängt auch die ausbeutung an dass
man nicht offen darüber spricht dann
fängt auch an dass man die leihmutter
unsichtbar machen muss und entwerten
muss als wäre sie gar nicht da im
gegensatz dazu dass sie einen teil der
familie ist
ich würde allerdings nicht sagen dass
sie das kind nur ausgeliehen bekommen
hat weil ich mache ja die positionen der
schwangeren stark und ich finde da der
punkt ist dass wir rechtliche
rahmenbedingungen schaffen müssen die
der den schwangeren erlauben eine
selbstbestimmte schwangerschaft zu haben
auch wenn es leihmütter sind und sie
geben durchaus etwas sehr sie sind auch
die biologischen mutter dieser kinder
sie haben nicht nur ein
embryo ausgeliehen und den sie dann
wieder zurückgeben wenn er reif ist
sondern sie sind aktiv an diesem kinder
gebären prozess beteiligt und sie müssen
rechte haben und an diesen rechten
müssen wir arbeiten und müssen die
definieren und damit wir die würde
dieser frauen schützen aber das geht nur
wenn wir offen darüber sprechen und wenn
es nicht so unter dem teppich gekehrt
wird und alle tun so als wäre da gar
nichts weil alles ist doch ganz
natürlich und wenn man mal unter den
teppich guckt es da gar nicht natürlich
sondern alles technologisch also
technologisch simulierte natürlichkeit
und das ist das größte problem gut aber
ich möchte einen schritt zurückgehen
weil man könnte doch auch einfach sagen
das ganze kinderkriegen das unterliegt
doch einer unverfügbarkeit hartmut rosa
macht dieses konzept der unverfügbarkeit
ja auch stark weshalb sollte ein kind
denn nicht einfach um verfügbar sein und
man macht alles damit plötzlich möglich
ist wie stehen sie dazu
ja weil wir das können ich meine aber
was heißt können auch dürfen sollen
müssen ja wenn man könnte ethisch
begründen warum man es nicht dürfen soll
wenn es so zu sagen wo ist ja also man
muss doch in etlichen grund haben warum
es nicht warum es ethisch bedenklich
sein das hat ja das hat ja frau baumann
hervorgebracht hat aber das betrifft die
kommerzialisierung und die ausbeutung
der frauen das ist ethisch gut
begründbar und da sind wir ja gar nicht
unterschiedlicher meinung das ist
skandalös aber warum ist es ethisch
bedenklich wenn zum beispiel eine mutter
von schwulen paar sagt ich strack für
dieses kind aus und nehmen dafür die
technologie in anspruch die wir jetzt
haben was ist daran und wie finden sie
das unethische baumann hölzle
es ist in dem sinne unethisch wenn wir
eben alle lebens bezüge
kommerzialisieren und das kind plötzlich
zu einem auftragsverhältnis wird und
noch einmal oder wir diese für
reproduktionsmedizin wenn wir sie
ausweiten
sie steigt immer über so individuelle
altruistische motive wird sie quasi gibt
es neue
legitimationen aber es ist immer das
steigbügel für die industrie um nachher
wirklich hier in brighton man dann auch
zu kommerzialisieren und das ist ja die
frage wo also das ist meine frage an sie
ja sehen sie irgendwo eine grenze dass
wir menschen die wir menschen ziehen
sollen was wir nicht verkaufen sollen
dürfen gibt es wie sie eine solche
grenze gibt es die nicht
also ich meine grenze ist die würde der
person auch selbst zu entscheiden und
ich finde wie gesagt nicht die
wirtschaftlichen aspekte das
problematische an der jetzigen
leihmutterschaft sondern die rechtlichen
wie zum beispiel ermöglichen dass solche
agenturen oder kliniken den schwangeren
frauen vorschreiben was sie essen dürfen
was sie nicht essen dürfen wohin sie
reisen dürfen welche medizinischen
untersuchungen sie machen wird dürfen
usw
das war in indien ja ganz schlimm da
wurden die frauen teilweise eingespart
das geht eben nicht und da müssen wir
sagen eine schwangere kann machen was
sie will sie kann so viel kaffee trinkt
man so viele zigaretten rauchen wie sie
will
und egal was für ein embryo in ihrem
mitbruder es ist das darf ihr niemand
verbieten sie ist ein freier mensch auch
wenn sie schwanger ist und dann hat man
ja die kommerzialisierung soll ein
bisschen eingelegt weil dann manche
wunsch eltern sagen oh das risiko ist
mir zu groß dass sie am ende was macht
mit meinem im trio was ich nicht so oder
so
das wäre dann die tatsächlichen sommer
natürlichen risiken wenn ich meine
schwangerschaft einer anderen anvertraut
schob ich das leider rechtlich nie
glücklicher aufgabe auf die uhr zu
schauen und diese und dieses gespräch
etwas langsam gegen ende zu lenken und
wir dürfen nicht das kind vergessen das
schwächste glied sie haben gesagt die
frau kam mit den ganzen wollens
argumenten das kind kann das eben nicht
wollen wo es hin kommt es kann es
natürlich aber trotzdem gibt es viele
argumente in bezug auf das kindeswohl
eines ein argument auch unserer
zuschauerinnen regula lehmann von der
stiftung zukunft schweiz die übrigens
auch schon hier als gast war sie sagt
die wichtigste frage wäre ob die kinder
das wollen die antwort ist einfach kein
kind würde freiwillig wählen mit der
geburt das erste
trennungs trauma erleiden zu müssen frau
könig also dem muss ich jetzt leider
ziemlich entschieden widersprechen
denn es gibt durchaus studien also ich
selber kenne natürlich kinder die sich
leihmutterschaft geboren worden sind die
sind jetzt aber tatsächlich noch ein
bisschen zu klein um diese frage
wirklich abschließend beantworten zu
können
aber es gibt durchaus forschungsgruppen
also es gibt eine forschungsgruppe an
der uni cambridge
mit dieser 30 40 jahren nur zu diesen
themen familie erforscht und unter
anderem eben oder vielfach auch zu neuen
re produktionstechnologien und die auch
unter anderem geforscht haben zu den
kindern die durch leihmutterschaft
entstanden sind und dort ist es wirklich
so dass sie es überhaupt keine hinweise
darauf gibt dass diese kinder irgendwie
ein trauma erlitten haben
total viele kinder die in dieser studie
erwähnt wurden waren total indifferent
ihrer entstehungsgeschichte gegenüber
den war das tatsächlich so ein bisschen
egal das ist was was sozusagen von
außenstehenden kommentatorinnen im
schnell als im visier hochgradig
befremdlich empfunden wird aber das sind
natürlich auch alles wirklich so
gesellschaftliche vorstellungen und in
dem moment und das sind natürlich im
familien gewesen in denen offen mit
dieser thematik umgegangen wäre dann
diese kinder ja gewusst dass ich durch
leihmutterschaft entstanden sind
offensichtlich gibt es aber kontexte in
denen es diesen kindern gut geht in
denen die jetzt kein trennungs trauma
haben und in denen die auch also da
wurden auch diverse psychologische tests
gemacht in denen es überhaupt keine
hinweise auf irgendwelche irgendwie
gearteten abweichungen gab
und insofern würde ich jetzt einfach mal
diese forschung die seit vielen jahren
läuft mich darauf wirklich oder darauf
wirklich beziehen wollen denn es gibt
keine hinweise darauf
das problem sind eigentlich wirklich
immer die kontexte in den etwas
stattfindet also wie wird es gehandhabt
ideen familien damit um die geht die
gesellschaft damit um und dann ist aber
schon eben die frage ist es nicht an uns
als gesellschaft anders damit umzugehen
müssen müssen das wirklich wie die
einzelnen familien einfach dann
verzichten
da würde ich aber doch kritisch
nachfragen wollen wird ist es denn nicht
so dass das kind letztlich einfach
funktionalisiert wird und zwar zugunsten
der um der reproduktiven freiheit
ausdruck zu verleihen
da wäre meine gegenfrage wie ist das
denn bei anderen formen der reproduktion
also wie ist das denn es ist ist es
wirklich immer wohl total
uneigennütziger altruistischer wunsch
ein kind in freiheit zu almer ziehen
sobald ich übertreibe natürlich
überspitzt hier sehr aber das ist
natürlich da kommen wir finde ich so ein
bisschen zum kern der sache denn
grundsätzlich ist es auch so dass wenn
wir leihmutterschaft und familien die
durch leihmutterschaft entstanden sind
mit natürlich in anführungsstrichen ich
finde auch in schwierigen begriff
entstandenen familien mal vergleichen
sind glaube ich die ähnlichkeiten
wesentlich größer als die unterschiede
ich gebe die frage an sie weiter also
vom kindswohl her denke ich kann man
nicht gut argumentieren gegen die
leihmutterschaft sofern die kinder
wirklich informiert sind darüber der
ursprung gewesen ist auch wenn wir schon
ganz zentral ist für die neuregelungen
und die entwicklung dass sie wissen was
wo her was haben sie für genetische
verwandtschaft ist übrigens auch wichtig
im hinblick darauf auf spätere dann
wiederum partnerschaften und so weiter
für mich sind zwei dinge entscheidend in
diesem zusammenhang die
in-vitro-fertilisation ist ja eine
notwendigkeit für die leihmutterschaft
und hier sind wir nach wie vor jahr
nicht ganz sicher ob hätten nicht die
die nährlösung der
in-vitro-fertilisation negativer aus
gesundheitlichen aktive auswirkungen hat
bei den kindern das ist nach wie vor
etwas ein thema das weltweit auch
debattiert wird angeschaut weil es
vielleicht epigenetischen veränderungen
kommt das ist noch dass eine vom
medizinisch das kind und das anteil ist
natürlich nur weil jetzt in natürlichen
eltern schafften kinder
instrumentalisiert werden auch
geschlagen werden und zweiter das heißt
ja nicht dass ich dann diese handlungen
nur weil sie sonst auch vorkommen
legitimierte also
die frage ist ja noch einmal in was für
einer welt leben wir und wir eine welt
leben in denen frauen nicht gleiche
rechte haben und am schluss ist ihnen
nur bleibt quasi eine ihre eigene
ausbildung zu finanzieren oder ihre
kinder zu ernähren
quasi leihmutter zu sein dann haben wir
dort ein problem und so lange wie diesen
rahmenbedingungen nicht haben finde ich
ist es müßig darüber auszutauschen und
das ist ja auch nicht gratis ist meines
können sich nur eine ganz bestimmte
gesellschaftliche schicht kann es sich
überhaupt leisten dass ein kind der
leihmutterschaft zu bekommen und das ist
auch eine gerechtigkeitsfrage es für
mich ist es deshalb ganz stark sind dass
gerechtigkeitsfrage natürlich emotional
sprich spricht sind wir alle endlich bei
den menschen die sich ein kind wünschen
und kann nicht bekommen aber
gleichzeitig finde ich es hat so viele
kinder auch in der schweiz die auch auf
die unterstützung brauchen die betreuung
brauchen eltern die sich wünschen würden
sie würden auch unterstützt werden dass
wir hier unsere in seinem muttergefühle
und nach weiter gefühle auch noch anders
leben könnten also wie man jetzt mit
adoption konkret bei station aber auch
sonst mit seit das aus pflegefamilien
und so weiter das haben entschuldigen da
muss ich mal eben kurz eingreifen denn
es ist tatsächlich so dass ich jetzt aus
meiner eigenen forschung sagen kann dass
es einen ganz großen teil von wunsch
eltern gibt die gerne kinder adoptiert
hätten und die aus diversen gründen
keine arbeit keine kinder adoptieren
durften also sie haben das beispiel
vorhin genannten mit wie
gleichgeschlechtlichen paaren
dann haben wir zum beispiel eltern die
irgendwelche vorerkrankungen haben wo es
vielleicht jetzt von den adoptions
behörden nicht unbedingt schriftlich ist
aber durchaus die
die praxis so ist dass diese eltern
einfach kein kind bekommen werden und
wir haben wesentlich mehr eltern die ein
kind adoptieren möchten als kinder die
zur adoption freigegeben werden also da
ist es tatsächlich so dass die empirie
diesem argument was ja ganz ganz oft
wunsch eltern entgegen gebracht wird und
wo wäre ich auch immer wieder von den
wunsch eltern erfahren wie extrem
schmerzhafter ist dieses auch warum habt
ihr nicht adoptiert es gibt so viele
kinder und wenn ich hier dann anderswo
in ich will das gar nicht aber dass das
dann so punkte wo wir auch noch mal
schauen müssen ob es nicht vielleicht
auch in der gesellschaft an sich oder
auch von tanner von dieser richtung aus
änderungen erfordert wie sie ja auch
argumentiert haben dass wir wirklich
eben andere andere familien form
ermöglichen müssen diese möglichkeiten
gibt es aber de facto momentan nicht für
die leider schon am schluss liter müssen
in die schlussrunde kommen frau schob
ich möchte ihn gern noch das wort geben
auch dass sie beschreiben können wie
denn würde von der leihmutterschaft für
sie ausschaut also das kindeswohl ist
natürlich ganz wichtig und es ist
wichtig dass wir als gesellschaft
definieren was ein kind braucht das ist
zuwendung gesundheitsversorgung
ernährung alle möglichkeiten sich zu
entwickeln und das müssen wir als
gesellschaft sicherstellen
ich behaupte aber und ich glaube da gibt
es eben auch diese studien dass es nicht
von der familien form der eltern abhängt
also es kann gute bedingungen für das
kindeswohl geben in leihmutter
entstandenen familien wie ihnen ganz
normal und andersrum also es hängt nicht
mehr der familienform zusammen sondern
wir müssen das qualitativ definieren was
wir als kindeswohl haben wollen
ich bin der meinung dass wir die frage
eben größer diskutieren müssen als
procontra leihmutterschaft sondern die
frage wie in welcher gesellschaft wollen
wir leben welche familienformen wollen
wir haben wie können wir im menschen den
ich schwanger werden können
wie können die eltern werden unter
achtung der würde derer die schwanger
werden können und das daneben machen
müssen weil wenn sie es nicht machen
gibt es keine kinder
und da wünsche ich mir dass die freiheit
der der schwangeren auch über ihre
schwangerschaft zu entscheiden
ich wäre dafür eben die jetzigen
schlechten praktiken der
leihmutterschaft durch die rechtliche
tagung der position der leihmutter zu zu
bekämpfen also dass man sagt sie kann
ich wäre sogar dafür leihmutterschaft
und adoptionsrecht tendenziell
miteinander zu verschmelzen
da kann man eben auch überlegen welche
rechte haben die wunsch eltern haben
nämlich meiner meinung nach viel zu
viele rechte gegenüber den leihmüttern
zum beispiel auch das recht auf
herausgabe des kindes also wir müssen
überlegen welche rechte sie wollen wir
denn den spannenden geben über ihre
schwangerschaft und über das was mit dem
kind passiert zu entscheiden so dass
ihre würde und ihre freiheit gewahrt
wird und das ist das was wir diskutieren
müssen und was wir momentan nicht
diskutieren weil wir das illegalisiert
aber wir haben hier einen grundstein für
diese diskussion gesetzt leider ist die
diskussion auch schon knapp am ende eine
kurze antwort wird das leihmutter diese
dieses verbot der leihmutterschaft in
der schweiz wird sich das verändern
das ist ein so gesehen die erfahrung ist
dass sich alles in dem sinne dann auch
so genannte neue akzeptiert wird
meine botschaft ist einfach vergessen
wird die industrie dahinter nicht von
ihnen ein letztes wort dazu würde von
einer leihmutterschaft wie schaut die
aus also ich kenne familien die eine
meiner meinung nach würde volle
leihmutterschaft praktiziert haben und
ich bestimmt natürlich vollkommen mit
ihnen überein dass das mit der
kommerzialisierung problem ist es gibt
aber andere modelle es gibt nun profit
modelle
es gibt modelle wo leihmutter genau das
gleiche mitspracherecht haben und da
denke ich es nicht die technologie das
problem sondern eigentlich der umgang
damit und dass es durchaus arten und
weisen gibt das auf eine ethisch
vertretbarer weise zu praktizieren
vielen dank für dieses schönes
schlusswort ich danke ihnen ganz
herzlich soll könig vor baumann hölzle
frau schrupp und herbie pinto ganz
herzlichen dank
vielen dank dass sie dabei waren
ja die sternstunde philosophie widmet
sich jetzt den us-wahlen einem
schlüsselerlebnis und fragt was es für
uns alle zu bedeuten hat ich wünsche
ihnen einen ganz schönen sonntag bleiben
sie uns treu
[Musik]
[Applaus]